welcome to the dean's show and i have
a special guest here with us coming from
new york
sheik omar how are you good
i'm doing good so how are things in new
york
uh new york you know is uh at least
uh for the most part of the last 100
years
has been the you know capital of the
world
and uh so things are going according to
plan over here
and uh usually washington dc
um is can you know it can be considered
like the capital of
america but new york is really like the
capital of the world is where the united
nations is this is where
a lot of the world elite
has invested themselves now you talked
about
not too long ago how islam actually
saved france
can you give us the gist of the message
that you were trying to get out to the
world
yes so um i forget the name of the king
i think it was louis the
fourth or sixth maybe you can correct me
if you remember
but um you know the the crusades were
going on and so this was part of the
one of the one of the events of the
crusades and
uh the point was that uh
there was real statesmanship back then
you know
real statements ship and there was a
respect for
the what we can say the other uh
and uh so during uh one of these
crusades or one of these wars muslims
actually captured
the king and they could have done
anything
they could have killed him but they
uh did what usually is done in
situations like that
especially in those times which was to
ransom the prisoners of war
and he was treated just like any other
prisoner of war of course the ransom was
much more but you know he was returned
back to them
and so uh that's the muslims were the
first ones to
reach out to uh the franks
and this is during the abbasid empire i
mean muslims
had a uh confrontation with the orthodox
christians on the one side
um and so we were you know constantly
uh dealing with constant opal and
then on the other side uh was the franks
and so the muslims that time he reached
out to them
and he sent them many gifts he sent them
an elephant that was the first time an
elephant
got to a european continent and
it was the talk of the town this
elephant was the talk of the town
and then you know they sent him a water
clock
that would like you know using water
mechanics
uh would this ball would come out every
hour
so there would be like 12 windows and
the ball would come out every hour
and and make a noise which the the the
priests of that time thought was
devilish so they destroyed the clock
and then he had gave them many other
gifts you know gold plates
and silver plates and things like that
so
there were these you know noble
exchanges and there was trade between
the franks and the muslims
soon after that time and uh
and then you know um things changed
that's how it started and then things
changed after that
uh after five six hundred years so
uh we owe each other as people quite a
lot
because even technology which was
transferred
because this was you know the first you
could say cultural
show of that technology that the muslims
had at that time
and even when the prophet said and
that the ummah would produce its rabb
meaning the ummah of muhammad would
produce its own master
is one of the ways you can look at that
saying of the prophet
so we transferred technology that made
them interested
in us and and and that's how it kind of
like that's one of the first
like reach out we have something we can
benefit with each other
happened and and so you know then they
started getting the knowledge we had
but we treated them overall much better
uh even though we made mistakes too
but we we have overall treated them much
much better
than they treated us especially the
french
especially the french because the french
have massacred the muslims
i mean especially in algeria yeah you
had like
how many over a million innocent human
beings who were terrorized depressed
is that the small number or what's the
conservative number
would you say uh the conservative number
like
so you know the government's like france
gives one number
algeria gives another number but a third
party
hundred thousand seven hundred thousand
yeah people dragged to the streets i
mean tied to cars you have uh
to this day you have skulls i mean
where's
france supposed to be some of the most
civilized people but
still collecting skulls to this day of
yeah it's very weird
isn't it weird how do you how do we
relate that today what do you think when
you see i mean france is supposed to be
the champion of liberty equality
universal rights human rights
but then you see the oppression of the
minority there and you
have specific laws for instance a person
is now mandated to wear a mask over
there
but if that same woman wears a niqab she
can get fined they're a ticket is that
correct
yeah you have 70 70 houses or more of
worship
houses of worship where people are
coming to worship the creator of the
heavens and earth
the same way jesus moses it's not a new
religion the same way of life that they
all preached in practice they're just
continuing that legacy so those houses
of worship are getting shut down
charities where the charities the
muslims are out there trying to
eradicate poverty
and now under this whole print pretext
of what of what's the pretext the excuse
and now they're shutting everything down
and oppressing the small group of people
there
yeah so there are two three things that
are uh happening
number one is that france specifically
has an allergic reaction to islam
and uh you know even amongst european
countries
uh france has a very big uh
allergic reaction different islam
because
of its own past and you know the muslims
that are in france are the same ones
that they colonized
you know there's a reason there's a
reason that happens that's ironic how
that's very interesting so you oppress a
people
colonize them you drive them out of
their country so now they come by you
and now you're telling them to go back
home yeah
and and see there there there's two two
level i mean there's
there's a whole bunch of issues here uh
the first issue
is uh like for example in the us okay so
they have this
judeo-christian morality okay
judeo-christian morality
when it does something wrong it feels uh
like it feels bad like they have a sense
of guilt
right so then they say okay you know
black lives matter
you know yes we shouldn't have done this
but they keep doing it
so it's like they do it but they also
want to feel not guilty
okay the french take that to the next
level because
uh christianity is basically vanished
from there in terms of their
their recent history so their sense of
guilt is not they don't feel like they
have to justify
like if let's say we had red indians in
in france and let's say if we had blacks
and friends they wouldn't feel that they
need to necessarily
justify that guilt that's inside them
because it wouldn't simply be there
okay and so then they just say simply
what they really feel
okay and so that's that's one aspect and
and and with what's coming in the world
the next
phase in the world where now israel will
take over
uh a lot of the geopol political
situation it's going to be exactly like
that it's not going to be like america
where if they do wrong then there is a
collective consciousness that
partly feels bad and the other is like
no no it's okay
we did this there's like this internal
struggle of good and bad within
it's not going to be like that in the
next phase of human history
and and so let me go back to friends the
first
problem uh from the modern times
happened with the very idea of
nationalism
yeah to me uh nationalistic flags are
the modern idols
you can say modern idols okay so the the
current flags say that again the last
part yeah i mean these are new and these
are just the new you know every
century there's a new form of shirk you
can say
you know [ __ ] changes its faces many
times
and so one of the shaykhs of this
century
or this last century the new shikh of
mankind
started really in france with
nationalism you see the french
revolution
brought nationalism so now instead of
you know standing up to god you're
standing up to this flag you're like
venerating these borders artificial
borders
uh you're venerating these artificial
borders as if they
have intrinsic meaning in themselves and
so you know this
idea of like american exceptionalism for
example
or french people think that they have
their their exceptional
just because they are french so like
literally
i mean dividing people based upon
borders of ethnic groups
uh in europe particularly in in america
um and then saying okay you know this is
how we're going to get along
but the whole thing is set up uh pretty
much as a caste system
uh now having said that when you have
divided yourselves as
a as as a nationalistic group then
demographics become
important you see and so the fear
and the fear in america american some
american intellectuals especially the
neocons
and the fear in in france is that
what are we going to do in the when the
when the culture
essentially changes right what are we
going to do
when uh there are less white people
or their influence decreases and they're
more of the minorities
now this is a very important point
because the quran mentions this point
you see when there are two western
prophets in the quran
and you see western civilization starts
from egypt
okay western civilization starts from
egypt so there's one prophet
who came into egypt which was yusuf
and one prophet that left egypt which
was musa
okay and so when yusuf was coming in
the statement that was made about him
and musa was exactly the same
they said the like the the
the minister when he was buying him he
said
we will take him as a son oh yeah or
he'll benefit us
and then when uh imran when the wife of
musa in the in the waters she said oh
we'll take him as a son or he'll benefit
us exactly the same word
see the west has this policy of taking
others in
but that policy changed when bani israel
was becoming too big
so now those now that the governments
had changed
the dynasties had changed the same
people are there
but now the tipti tribe which was the
pharaohs
ruling tribe they were less in number
bani israel were growing in number
and that became a big problem and that's
when firaoun started to kill off the
boys
one year after another year after i mean
every other year
he was killing out the boys in order to
reduce their population
because they have to somehow control
these demographics and that's a very
fearful thing for them so when you have
a country based upon nationalism on the
one side
and then you see the demographics
changing
okay the influence circles changing
and so you know uh so these are the
people yes you did influence you did
want their resources at one time you
went out and got them
then you felt bad and you said okay fine
fine come over here
you know we like some of you elite one
because what the way it starts right
so first there was like imperialism
direct imperialism
the indirect imperialism actually was
meant for the elite of those societies
to come
to these societies get indoctrinated and
go back
and uh rule over there that was like the
the main idea uh but then it became what
it became because there's some good
people
so they have some good policies and then
you have the
the the main agenda there too so
muslims started coming into france into
different european countries
uh and then now they're worried wait we
got too many
babies being born like literally in
france for like every
french child born there's like 10 muslim
kids born
like in the hospital if you go to the
the
the the the the you know the the
hospital where the children are being
born there'll be 10
10 muslim children to one
french person even mentions
will give you strength with wealth and
children
so this this process of you know
where allah gives us more children and
this is one of the big problems
is that the the european world is
reaching its old age and the muslim
world is reaching its young age meaning
in terms of the larger population
so the muslim world has more young
people
than old people the western world is
coming to a point where they're going to
have more old people
to the young people and they're very
worried about what is that going to do
the
to the economics to the economics of the
whole
society so that's another word so
there's the demographics worry
but with the demographics there's a big
worry about okay
we're like reaching our old age and we
have less
because they produce less so they have
less young people
more old people comparatively muslims
have more
uh less older people more younger people
because more young people were produced
i think uh somebody wrote a book
uh saying that you need to produce an
average of like 2.5
on average per family to keep
civilization going
right so that num they've gone under
that number
even in the u.s it's under that number
unless you include these hispanic people
how do you connect also now austria
austria has also coined now they have a
new term and a new fight
kind of similar because of some attacks
that happen there and obviously we
condemn that
we don't condone anything like that
that's very clear but to go ahead and
take some
isolated incidences and then to go ahead
and now smear a whole group of
almost 2 billion people so now they are
under that pretext
gonna go ahead and start you know
probably doing the same thing oppressing
the muslims those who want to submit to
the one
and only creator of the heavens and
earth so have you heard this term in
this fight now
in austria uh i don't know specifically
about austria but the idea of political
islam is
is very important because you see where
this is very important to understand
what i'm about to say inshallah right
now i think it'll be beneficial
and that is that you see the world is
looking for a system of justice
okay the world is looking for a system
of justice and has been for the last 200
years we've gone from
you know communism to socialism to
democracy we've tried this we've tried
that
and you and so the humanity is thirsty
for a system that will show justice
but secularism demands that all
religions be made equal
you see and so you can't really show any
one religion
in its full uh in its full
form so if you establish so so the
biggest threat
is that if you establish a real islamic
society
where you can bring in the western
intellectuals for example
or you can bring in the intellectuals
the world and say come and see see the
society how this functions
a society that would have no alcohol a
society that functions without drugs a
society that
you know does not allow uh
the the sexual anarchy where women are
literally becoming objects
right you know in islam when we're
talking about the french this like ties
in
like this whole thing and you know the
jazz biggest
attack one of its biggest attacks will
be on women because they'll convince
the women that we're actually giving you
freedom which in fact
is like completely it's completely the
opposite
because in islam you give a
private sp like not private you give a
sacred space to women
you can't address a female in islam
unless she addresses you
meaning it's like she is royalty you
can't
i can't just go in in the street and
start i like what you said so the woman
in islam is like royalty
and uh what do you mean like when you
say uh the
the the go ahead yeah you know everyone
has their
personal space and then their social
their social space in terms of friends
and you of your public space
but islam adds a severe special sphere
for women
doesn't it doesn't allow what's
prevalent like in france another play
where you got the
groping phenomena yeah yeah so
you know that's an actual epidemic in it
of itself
absolutely i mean uh you know just the
those whole sexual anarchy in all of
all of the world really even the muslim
world for that matter
but it you know it stems from these
ideas uh
that freud has and and you know where he
felt that sex was the biggest human urge
and then now you know everyone and
there's a sexual anarchy and when
there's sexual anarchy what does that
mean
that means that you know well your
society is going to go down because
you'll have less children yeah
less families but you said now you you
listed a a bunch of uh concepts in islam
uh in their family in their preservation
you know of the rights of women all
these things that they don't know about
but
this coming from what they call this far
right element they actually i've
interviewed people who are part of these
parties but when they looked into islam
they actually connected with all of
these concepts that's the ironic thing
is a very important point where you're
mentioning especially in the us
that see most the the the
the the the people that decide the
liberal side
is not palatable to muslims from moral
perspective
even though they're nicer to us they're
nicer to us
but they're not palatable to us in terms
of long-term
relationship that would be meaningful
on the other side you have the ashabul
the republican the conservative you have
that the neoconservatives
if we overlook the fact they don't like
us and we work with the conservatives
and we because they're the kitab so
there is a common
basis between us and them we have to
overlook
the fact that they don't like us and we
have to find segments within the people
of arun kitab that we can work with
as a as a community in order to move
forward
because moving forward with the liberals
that's that's just a dead end
that's just the atheists and then the
neoconservatives the complete right side
that's also just
just not gonna work we have to find the
right
alliances that we have to work with uh
you know the right type of christians
like
a lot of black christian christian
churches would work
hispanic christian churches would work
um
they because you know they wouldn't be
on
completely on the right side of the
neocon agenda either
let me let me uh i got a lot of things i
want to cover we have a short amount of
time
so now you have we mentioned okay
political islam islam complete way of
life covers all these things
my point was is that they're scared of
muslims establishing
a model because they're two islams
there's an islam islam
islam as a muslim you can say is how you
you know
your mode of worship you where you pray
how you pray
your rituals your birth your marriage
your death your rituals
your lead your halal your haram in terms
of food your clothing
okay they don't mind that that's
palatable
to secular to the secular society
but if you talk about an islam that will
fully express itself
as a system with its own economic system
where there's no ribba
which is heaving havoc on this society
interesting interest yeah interest
you know this is also this is also
prohibited in the in the bible
isn't it prohibited in the bible
prohibited in the bible had
been considered prohibited in
christianity till the
until the 15th century yeah so nothing
nothing is new here i mean that's
another proof of islam
islam meaning submission to the creator
that you don't find in the bible
and then when you you see you said you
said a term that might get us you know
you know in some trouble but this is
this is like the ten commandments this
is the divine law this is from
the creator when moses went up and get
the law this is this is what we're
talking about sharia it's mentioned over
200 times in the bible actually
shariah as mentioned in the bible so
this is what jesus
uh also called to moses noah the last in
the final measure prophet muhammad but
isn't this a
another proof of islam that not only
does it give you the blueprint to run
your life but again it's a blueprint to
run
society humanity to make it more
peaceful
just because no justice no peace so to
make
justice prevail so peace can prevail
it's a complete blueprint for everyone
for the individual and society first
steps for that is that you know families
have to be given
power back as families the secular state
takes away
power from the families i can't educate
my children the way i want them to be
educated i cannot
uh you know live uh where
i cannot live independently uh as a
family as a
as a group as family members you know
everything has to be registered
everything has
that's the attack that's the attack now
in france they're they're actually even
denying home school now they are at the
young ages of
four or five they're also trying to take
this away
yeah and so you know they think somehow
the state
has more compassion than the parents
would and so you know they've done the
same thing with parenting you know they
take a few bad parents
and then use that as an excuse to take
away the rights of parents
across the board and the same thing is
being done with muslims
but they are really scared that if islam
should rise
i mean imagine all the big businesses
look all big businesses make money doing
haram
you know the big businesses like loaning
money for example
alcohol cigarettes these these these the
people that are making the money in the
world
okay and so you know there's very few
exceptions to that but majority of the
rich people they
do they become rich doing wrong things
yeah if you here's another example in
islam you cannot have corporations
in which you can sue the corporations
but not those who run the corporations i
mean since when does this make sense
right and so you you know some person he
runs a corporate
corporation he gets his golden parachute
which is the money they give him
when he's gonna retire because he's been
doing very bad
he's stolen millions of people's money
and uh
and so you know and and and now you have
you run after the corporation
and not the people right that's haram in
that
people that are running a corporation
are respond meaning running a business
are responsible for that business you
cannot have corporations in islam in the
sense that we have them today
and anyway sorry so good points really
good points
before we go on to the next thing i want
to cover uh
this is also we'll move on from the
france and this austria where you had
these uh
attacks that happen that we condemn and
but you had things that are uncovered
and that's what you can also touch upon
critical thinking
right that certain things are fed to us
and allah god almighty in the quran
tells us to when it comes to us
you know to verify to check to crit use
some you know the gift that allah gave
you but not just be like sheep just
blindly following everything that the
mainstream media is pushing out
and you had some instances where you had
certain people screaming allahu akbar
and then they unfolded that no they
weren't muslim but they were trying to
pretend to be muslim did you hear about
that
and then you had then you had also a
priest on priest fighting
but then that doesn't get covered right
but as soon as now
someone again identifies as a muslim or
you got some lunatic that
you know they can put and put muhammad
as his name or whatever or
abdullah or something then mainstream
media just
runs with it all day and night hypocrisy
and double standards
that when you when you when you try to
understand
the system of disinformation one of the
key elements is
is that look if i have my news station
and you have your new station
and somebody else has their own news
station so one is cnn the other is abc
the other is whatever so if we're all
running our own independent news
we would all be showing different news
right
because there's so much happening in the
world right
uh there's so much happening in the
world that there's enough space
for us to more than 50 of our news would
be different from one another
okay but the fact that you know the news
the whole news media the whole
industry runs with the same news okay
is itself very problematic and shows
that the
the level of the level of insincerity or
the level of
there's no genuineness they're all
running with the same headlines
whereas in the world there's there's
hundreds of things that are happening
that are not reported that are just as
interesting really
okay so so for example in america
uh there was no hardly any talk about uh
the wars that were happening between
azerbaijan
and armenia for example this is an
example but that's happening but no one
talks or does talk or focus but the
focus is always the same
which makes no sense from an industry
from a perspective as an industry
because if you
if you go back to the even in the u.s
when the u.s
used to be us i consider that you know
when
when america was like i was born in the
70s so the america of the 80s and 90s
was very different than the america that
we were here
when we were young we had news reporters
actual
news reporters reporting on corporate
america uh
people actually going out doing
investigative journalism
right which has now gone down it doesn't
hardly exist
investigative journalism now it's all
about everyone having the same headlines
the same headlines the same headlines
and so this uh this now seems to
be more like a akin to like propaganda
than actual news and and that's one of
the problems and then
uh you know along with it come many
other issues but if brother if i can go
back to friends i was mentioning the
allergic reaction friends has
especially to nevada and hijab you see
that there is a idea called the
panoctagon
and the idea of the panoptagon is that
you have to be able to see
others and while others cannot see you
this is
jeremy bentham one of the philosophers
of of of england
came out with this idea that the key to
power
is that you see your opponent but you
cannot and they cannot see you
when the french took over the muslim
world one of the biggest complaints that
their generals had
is that even though we occupied their
land we cannot see
them because the women were wearing nip
up
okay so now even though you conquered
the the land you don't psychologically
feel in control because you don't see
the what you conquered you don't see
your trophy sort of thing
and uh and so this became a big national
debate in france
this whole phenomenon became a big
national debate
and so he the issue of hijab and the
issue of nipah
has been in debate in france and very
strong
what they in their own words masculine
voices
very strong masculine voices in fact it
went to the point where
um they even gathered women
uh and forced nico out of them just to
be able to take their pictures to say
because they didn't feel they can show
off to the elite
that they have to without showing
pictures see their nikons are off
that's like the complete takeover the
complete takeover is
that you know we got them to take off
their nipple because they didn't
psychologically feel because now they've
you know in the streets women are
walking
and they're covered you can't see them
and so that really bothered them
and and and and anyway people have
written about this and it really
captured their
fantasy their desire to like rape
if i may say rape the muslim woman you
know
in terms of control and so this this is
carried on
and it carries on in france out of other
western countries
more than uh any other place so what do
you think how do you
apply critical thinking skills at this
time
day and age where we understand that
when they talk about
in the media about islam and certain
things are put out there the people who
know islam they know okay this is false
they see they learn islam from the books
from the quran and the sunnah that
promotes justice peace
love happiness family unity all these
beautiful beautiful concepts and this is
what draw peoples to it the pure
monotheism all these other things and
we can go on and on about that but then
you hear in the media and then it's
something totally different but we can
recognize it
but then a lot of times the media
becomes like for a lot of
muslims themselves magic and they just
take everything that cnn fox news
uh and all the other pundits out there
give them and they don't question and as
soon as you start to question you do
critical thinking
what allah is commanding you to do now
labels start getting put put out
conspiracy theorists
and other labels and whatnot i think
part of your question
is how do we under how do we know or how
do we identify disinformation
yeah how do you identify in this day and
age there's so much information fake
news
and some people who go too far and they
start coming up with their own theories
but
obviously we know that shaitaan is out
there conspiring
day and night so now when you're not the
evidence doesn't point to
and it's not going down easy when what
the mainstream media is telling you
there's other there's other
sources of information uh independent
news sources and whatnot but and then it
contradicts the mainstream
and now a lot of times even as muslims
we have a hard time accepting that
yeah so you know uh over here there are
two three things and that
uh inshallah i think i can that have
beneficial have been beneficial to me
number one like i said when you see the
same headline across the board
then at least be suspicious same
headline across the board
be suspicious number one
number two is when you see a camera at
the right place at the right time
be suspicious okay so you know
somebody just happened to have their
camera on top of a building
at the right place at the right time and
they see
just exactly what was gonna it was like
as if it was pre-arranged
interesting you know so this idea of
pre-arranged
uh videoing is very very important
the other thing is if the scenario that
they present to you meets hollywood
standards of a movie
that's a good point okay so if because
it meets hollywood standards yeah so
i'll just give you an example and
i may be right i may be wrong but the
idea is right
okay the idea is right the point i make
meaning
the example i'm giving may be right or
wrong but the point is right
when this uh saudi uh brother kasoji
the journalist was killed in the saudi
embassy
okay and uh so what was said
you know somebody came and he was sawing
his bones and
and you know a special group of people
came there and
like when they make it into a hollywood
movie right
when they're saying okay they're cutting
off the necks you know like chopping off
necks that's a hollywood movie okay when
it meets when the story meets hollywood
uh a hollywood movie standard like
you're like oh that would make a good
scene
right as a director because they've
already captured our imagination with
these movies
so when they give us a story that meets
the standard of those movies
it already comes with certain ideas and
certain music behind those scenes
certain ideas behind those scenes and so
we have a more
visceral reaction to that and for more a
stronger reaction to that
because we've been you can say there's
been this internal
predictive programming so when they make
a news event
sound like it's a real news event but
the story is very much something you
would actually put in hollywood
there's you have to be very suspicious
if that's true or not
then of course uh you know in our case
we have the advantage of having a
prophet
that really told us about subhanallah
everything
you know i mean verifiably told us about
everything
i mean it's it's like you know uh
it you there's hardly anything in terms
of major events that he has not
pointed to in one way or the other and
so when you see
that uh like for example about news
media itself
just the quran itself i mean even before
the
sayings of our beloved prophet the quran
salallahu
regarding a certain group of people the
quran says
so this is now they want to extinguish
the light
with their mouths with the media when
you see
a certain media talking unjustly against
islam
that's a sign that see that that's that
becomes a litmus says wait
i know you're lying about this for sure
this is not islam
and you're running with this story and
don't tell me you're so naive that you
weren't able to figure it out that it's
not that bad
right that it's not like this so when it
is
when you are beyond the point of
it's not a matter of innocence when you
see
that they're intentionally saying things
about islam that are not true
then that is the litmus test that then
you have to really be careful about
everything else
and in fact you have to analyze
everything and then now you they are
actually giving you the ammunition
that you can now actually take their
stories that they're giving you
to peel the onion to see okay really
what's going on
because the assumption is that it's not
true
and you know there's this uh it's not
just islam it's it's sometimes
especially in the liberal media it's
attack on religion whether it's
christians
jews muslims religion traditional
traditional ideas
there's an attack on that regardless
and then of course with the republican
or the conservative
they thrive on anti-islamic uh
sentiments
because you know i mean it's like um
it's like the az because as hubble feel
you know in the time of abraham and when
they were going against the kaaba they
were also right-wing christians
okay and and so we have the right-wing
christians and the right-wing
or the the party of the elephant today
and so it's there's a lot of
similarities
yeah that's interesting because you'll
hear from one and there all this fake
news that they
they are very skeptical about but when
it comes to islam what they're fed they
just take it
yeah it's a complete double standard
here you see the contradictions
yeah so uh we can tell them come visit
us come hang out with us come have a tea
or coffee
visit your local mosque yeah wallahi i
mean all you have to do is just become
friends with somebody that goes to the
mosque and and it would
benefit in anybody tremendously
just not even from anything except
getting to know people that are more
peaceful
and i'm talking about internally
peaceful that you can
feel that when you're with muslims
inshallah
yeah one brother was telling me how he
uh he was friends with
one one christian and conservative
conservative christian
and he was really respecting the values
of islam he saw i mean and he was
impressed
and then he wanted to he went back to
his community and he wanted
you know to form some kind of connection
but he got a lot of uh
kickback from that he got a lot of
pushback from that
uh but when when when we talk about and
unfold you know the family values you
know
the morality code all these things the
concept of god the love of jesus his
mother mary
all these beautiful similarities you
know uh it's uh we have a lot in common
just to close up now and you connected a
lot with
the this term the jiao can you go ahead
and just
connect all of this uh these concepts we
have in islam towards in the times you
know
from the uh verbatim word of god
almighty the quran authentic
hadith that we have from the last of our
master prophet muhammad and the
understanding of the
the best of generations of sahabah uh
one thing that comes to mind where
you'll have you know people who are
truthful be looked at liars liars will
be looked as truthful this deception
will be foreign rampant
uh how do you equate that because you
talk a lot about this
about the the term the jail yes
um so we like christians look
we like the christians and the jews
believe
that there is a coming back of a messiah
okay we believe that the messiah is
coming back christians believe the
messiah is coming back the jews
also as many of their groups they
believe
the messiah is coming back and we like
them also believe
that they'll be false messiahs and so we
both agree that messiahs or or prophets
or somebody
saying i'm jesus is going to come back
and
we also believe that there will be liars
amongst them
and so this we have in common
where we uh where the christians
have a certain bias even though it's not
scriptural but the bias
is is that this antichrist will be
muslim
okay that this and this this feeling
even though
i want the christian brothers and
sisters to know
that throughout christianity throughout
christianity
throughout the history of christianity
it was always thought amongst christians
that the antichrist would be jewish
okay and the reason for that is that who
killed your god
you know or who who who you blame for
killing your god
is is the jewish people and i'm not
singling out jewish people
but i'm only saying that the narrative
at that time was
the jews hurt jesus and so it was
that is how they actually had good
relationships with muslims
and they didn't uh they didn't look at
muslims okay the antichrist will be
coming out from the muslims it was
unimaginable for
and and you have to remember something
very important um
uh one of the great uh you know uh
catholic philosophers actually said this
i forget his names right now
usually nations or civilizations that
share borders
is where conflict happens okay
so islam and christianity has shared a
border
for almost a thousand years okay and
when you share a border
conflict is inevitable at some point
between two people right
it's like having a neighbor for a
thousand years you're gonna run into
some problems sometime
right what what
the christian world and and therefore
even the muslim world has to realize is
that we've been neighbors for a very
very long time
and out of the 1400 years we've been
pretty good neighbors okay pretty good
neighbors for the majority of that time
and with the exception of maybe
300 years of crusades other than that
we've been pretty good neighbors
and we've had pretty good feelings
especially at the religious level
at the religious level christians
favorite muslims to the point that even
i'm sure you know this that even the
catechisms
of the of the catholics mentions that
muslims as a potentially saved group of
people
and uh i think it's catechism 814
something like this that says
you know those people that follow the
believe in the one true god follow the
way of abraham so on and so forth
christians had good feelings towards
muslims
for the majority of their history unlike
what media has done now
you see this all started with a bible
called uh which is like they're you know
like in
in in islam we have a primary uh
the uh we have a primary uh you can say
exegesis of quran explanation of quran
so they they came up with a new exegesis
of the bible
called the scotsfield bible okay i
believe that's when it's called the
scotsfield bible which was published by
oxford and then given to all the
christian seminaries for free
and that was the beginning of the
turning point uh
especially in the christian circles
where the anti-islamic sentiment started
to rise
number one number two uh
because of what happened with protestant
christianity
because uh you see when protestant
christianity is separated from catholics
now they are the jews and christians are
reading the same book
okay and the quran even mentions that uh
call it so this this kind of like quran
predicted this
kind of like change that would happen
and so
you'll see how i make this point so the
quran says the jews say
call it the jews say christians
have no claim they have they don't know
what they're talking about
and the christians said the jews have no
claim
and then allah says even though they're
both reading the same book
they're both saying they don't have a
claim even though old testament is
common between them
right and so they're they're both
pointing fingers so
this is one angle of history the other
angle of history is is that where
become jew or christian you'll be guided
this is the coming together of the
judeo-christian civilization
what has happened to christianity and
what christians have to realize
is that they have to unlock themselves
from this uh scotsfield bible
version of christianity that in the
modern times where it's been
completely detached from the past okay
the christianity of the past the
christianity of the forefathers the
christianity of
saint augustus the christianity of
martin luther the christianity of
all the big huge personalities of of
christianity of the past
are in complete antithesis of where
christianity is today
and so they themselves have to go back
to their own books
and and if they do this they will come
at the doorsteps of islam
you see the quran says o people of the
book and allah is talking here to the
christians and the jews
you don't have a claim there is the
you know the the myth of christianity
and then there is the
text of christianity you have to go back
to your own text
to actually see what your forefathers
were actually saying
and if you go back to the actual bible
you will find
that you have a lot more in common with
muslims
and you will appreciate everything from
hijab like the covering of the women
and in fact there are women christian
women
that this is becoming a popular thing
now again
in even in christianity in orthodox
places like in greek
in russia women are beginning to cover
themselves and and
a lot of thanks to islam for that and
even though unfortunately a lot of
muslim sisters are taking off the job
christian sisters are wearing the hijab
now but
the point i'm trying to make simply is
is that you need to go back to the text
of christianity
and see what your forefathers were
saying about those texts
not following the myth don't learn the
bible through the media
because that's just mythology thank you
very much
you're welcome thank you it was real
nice having you with us
and if people want to look you up where
can they find you
uh just type in shaykh merbelloch on
youtube and then you know
you'll find me jazakallah thank you
thank you for sharing that with us
spend some time with us we'll see you
next time inshaallah jazaklallahad
and thank you guys for tuning in to
another episode of the ding show
and what can we take away if you're
somebody who's new
to this channel and you're wondering
what muslims and islam are all about
you've seen that there's one thing that
you might get from the media
and that's something distorted but islam
is actually the house of peace and we're
all looking for peace and purpose
and that's what islam submission to the
creator not the creation gives you
invites you to the house of peace
because when you're connected with your
creator then you truly know yourself
and when you truly know yourself and
your purpose in life that's when you get
peace and contentment in life so if
you'd like to learn more call us
1-800-662-islam
ask those tough questions but start a
conversation
connect if you're a conservative
christian
if you're somebody who believes in the
creator of the heavens and earth
get to know the concept of god in islam
ask those tough questions
what do you guys believe do you really
believe what the media is telling us
what we've heard
ask the tough questions have a
conversation it's really that simple
because you understand that the media
lies that the media is about hype
there's a lot of propaganda
but there's a lot to learn and if your
mind is open like a parachute it's going
to work
we can have a conversation and you will
only benefit yourself and you got
nothing to lose but so much to gain
so continue to tune in here to the dean
show subscribe if you haven't already
hit that notification bell support us on
our patreon page
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you assalamu alaikum
and if you like this episode of the d
show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now